okay before I get started with the
actual content of this video I want to
apologize for the technical difficulties
that you might find in this video
because there are a couple of
quote-unquote jump cuts I don't know if
you can really call them jump cuts I
mean it's in the game in door it's not
really a regular kind of jump okay
anyway but the thing was that happened
was I was streaming this and there was a
certain set which was one this new water
castle and hopefully it's going to be
fixed because blackout resent me the
file
and thanks blackout by the way but
basically what happened was that thing
crushed every time so yeah this this
process of building this actually did
include quite a bit of crashing the game
and reopening it at nauseam and that was
a bit of a problem then there's also the
fact that I'm recording this for the
second time because I recorded this
prior to this but then audacity decided
to be a total jerk to me and decided to
after I compress my track suddenly crash
and that was not so nice but yeah what's
going on in this case would be that I'm
building a Romanian building and don't
worry this is going to be part of the
new park but before I wanted to get
started with that I just wanted to test
a couple of things now the Baltic theme
has for quite a while now been part of
that and I've already built a couple of
buildings with that and feels somewhat
safe to say that it's actually a really
cool theme for how underused I mean not
used at all it is because I I was pretty
not so sure about it at first because
maybe there had been people before who
actually used the Baltic theme but I am
pretty certain now that that is not
there's no such thing and the same guy
the same goes for this Romanian theme
though I'm probably better off call it
calling it a Transylvanian theme but
I'll probably address that later on if I
don't forget it so probably not because
I forget everything and the reason why I
wanted to do this is this is going to be
part of the new let's play park and
unlike in the last let's play park where
it was yo let's go into a let's play
park Yolo and let's build random things
and eventually ended up with a theme
that was medieval spooky steampunk
Alpine mmm yeah I kind of Miss a plan
this out and have certain areas
not go overboard with any terraforming
or over-the-top things but what to keep
the pike down-to-earth and realistic
quote-unquote realistic because this is
what like I'm taking three after all
that we're talking about so before I did
that one of the things that I wanted to
do before I got actually involved in
that Pike was to test the themes for a
number of reasons because obviously as
far as I know and I'm very very sorry if
this theme has actually been done before
but to my knowledge it hasn't been done
before and at least I haven't seen a
Romanian Pike ever before and I haven't
really heard anyone talk about it so I
feel I feel pretty safe talking about
this thing as if it's the first
remaining building at least that's it in
my experience so this building right
here as you may be able to tell it's my
first Romanian building over and that
sounds way too official it's my first
Romanian building by that I mean it's
just a small test to see if the theme
actually works as in if it actually
looks good if it can actually work in a
park content in a park context and if I
can actually work with it and if there
are actually custom scenery sets and
that was one of the bigger problems with
this entire theme because as you might
as you may also be able to tell Rome
Romanian custom scenery there is no such
thing and I guess it's a shame I haven't
really seen any Romanian people in the
community might be that I'm just missing
them but you know it I feel like they're
a very vocal minority and just a
minority in general in the community
which is a shame but yeah that goes for
many countries I think this is a couple
of weeks ago I find this Korean website
which had loads of awesome things on it
but the Korean community doesn't really
interact with the English community
because Korean is such a different
language and it's hard to learn English
if you if you're Korean and vice versa
and you get the drill just some parts of
the community that are very secluded
from the rest of the community but if
there are any Romanian people out there
actually watching this video - I love
you you're cool and I guess I might talk
about this it's a bit of a background
behind why I am doing this theme other
than it's something cool that nobody has
done before and I want it in my new
let's play park
I've been on a exchange program with the
Romanian school quite a while ago and
that that was I could be the best week
of my life well one of the best nom that
I'm looking back at it I was pretty
young at it at the time and pretty
immature and I feel like now would be
the better time to steal that that
experience from the two years ago silver
it and give it to the now currently
living silver though I might feel the
same about it
two years after saying this but
regardless of that I've seen things over
there and that was pretty pretty awesome
and the thing with this team is oh there
was a jump code but the thing with this
is it's got an interesting blend at
least the Transylvanian buildings do
it's got an interesting blend between
the classic Hall and Gothic Castle type
architecture but also the Alpine ish
architecture one of the things that
really struck me was how similar the
Romanian architecture was to the rest of
Europe but it still had that one thing
on it that said this is Romania and I
still don't entirely sure what that was
because building this building now I do
feel like it's more generic than just
Romanian but it's got influences from
all over Europe and also things that are
not in Europe and it's it's all blended
together and it's a wonderful mix and
that's why I decided to try this and it
turned out that that mixture of alpine
village and the castle set such as the
Walt Disney World console that you can
see a lot on this building is actually a
pretty damn good combination and I was
pretty surprised with that and this is
one of the reasons why I am pretty happy
about this building and when I say then
I'm happy about this building I don't
necessarily mean this is such an amazing
building and I like this building but
the points of this building was to see
whether this theme could actually work
in Rolla Kousaka 3 due to the
aforementioned things such as if this
custom scenery actually works and if it
actually works as something that you
could place in a theme park and that I
think is something that this building
has proven to me
and yes there are a couple of things
that are still bit vague about this
building like the purpose is still bit
of an awkward question when it comes to
this building aren't really not sure
what to do with this thing I kind of
turned it into a restaurant at some
point but there's also the fact that you
must have walkways all around this thing
because it doesn't really have a front I
mean the part with the tower is pretty
much the facade then the main part of
the building I guess but then again the
back side is also not looking that bad
and it does have that little path and a
restaurant in it so it's really hard to
decide what you can really do with it
and I feel like with a little bit of
tweaking you might actually be able to
turn this building into a station though
I would say that would be one
ridiculously over themed station though
that is probably not well I guess it's
not even that over themed I mean after
Lane anyway I'm digressing what I wanted
to kind of try with this building is
something that I think has succeeded
whether this building is something that
I like or not I think that it has
convinced me that a Romanian theme is
something that I want to try and I know
this is not the most Romanian theme I've
ever seen and I know that there will
also be people over there going mmm what
does it remain you even look like or is
remaining a country I thought more vanya
was over there but and I feel like this
is something I want to try because the
new park in the let's play and and I'll
address this tiny bit in some videos I
think but I'm forming more and more
plans on it as time goes on and as I
have more exams I know time to work on
it so that's why in my head it's all
developing and in the roller-coaster
country nothing is happening and I'm
really not sure how things will turn out
but the main idea is that so far I've
had the three themes of Baltic that I
really want to do and that I feel pretty
safe has some pretty cool influences
that I might want to use in the pike
anyway Romanian which I'm trying right
now and Dutch / Flemish which is still a
bit of a tough subject because I think
that there are quite a number of people
who have done the Dutch team before
especially in the
immunity now I wouldn't know because I'm
not really active at all in the Dutch
community but III do kind of remember
some Dutch people going yeah Holland
let's make stereotypical Dutch parks and
it is a theme that I would definitely
like to try because and I'm trying to be
as unbiased as I can here I do like the
Dutch architecture in a sense the only
problem with it and this is a problem
that also occurs for the Baltic theme
and the Romanian theme and it's
definitely going one going to be one of
the big problems of the park is that I
feel like there aren't really any good
Dutch / Flemish got some scenery sets
out there and I don't want to insult
anyone who already has the sets of them
for example city of cinn has an amazing
Dutch set out there but it's not
something like the classical Dutch
cities have in buildings and it's just
not the thing that I'm looking for in
the custom scenery sets so this is one
of the issues but aside from the obvious
custom scenery issues I feel like this
building is working out pretty well
the spire on top of the tower is
probably going to be subject to change
if I don't forget to change it and that
is because the spire currently doesn't
really fit I've been looking at some
buildings in Romania and they all have
some awkward spires I mean I wouldn't
necessarily say awkward they're pretty
cool it's just there's so much different
than all of the spires we currently have
in rollercoaster kanthri so I'm
definitely going to have to work and
work on some new spires if I really want
to continue on this and I would rather
do that than spend a lot of time trying
to get different custom scenery sets
together to get something that looks
like a spire that I want to have because
in the end then you get something that
looks cool from a distance but a bit
awkward if you zoom into it so I can't
wait to avoid that and that's primarily
the big issue at this point other than
that I feel like this building could
maybe potentially possibly I guess be
useful in a park if I really want to do
it and the one of the one of the only
issues that I have at the moment with
this is like I said I don't really know
what to do with it
and that's an issue because I don't
really know what kind of layout I'm
going to want to have in the let's play
Pike I guess you could call this video
kind of a prequel along along with the
other videos that I might produce before
I actually start doing the new let's
play Pike because it's not just a bit of
an experimentation to see if the themes
work but I also still need to get ideas
on how I'm going to work with the layout
of the pike because as I want to turn it
into a realistic pike I can't get away
with the rose gardens [ __ ] or logic
mentality and build huge consoles
everywhere and just say hey they're big
castles I don't care if they don't make
sense shape wise they're cool and yeah
I'm definitely going to have to focus
more on just very modest realism and
layouts and shapes and stuff like that
rather than less place enormous castles
and throw details on them like there and
no tomorrow
so yeah that's one of the issues that I
have with the park I guess at this point
so Andy I need to come up with some ways
to get a good layouts and work with that
that's one of the main pressing issues
at this point and something that I guess
hmm I can think about does it really
take too much in-game stuff but I'm
reconsidering for the first time of my
life actually planning a park as in
getting getting paint or my more
professional software and drawing things
drawing park layouts and see if anything
is really going to work because the
thing is I've always been a big fan of
let's open the game and do whatever and
let the creativity flow and just kind of
build a park like you're doodling but I
don't want to take that risk with this
thing because there are three new themes
and possibly even a fourth new theme
it's a completely new thing to me and I
don't feel like taking the risk of just
jumping into an empty sandbox and just
call me cars are in there and hope for
the best because it's normally I would
be okay with that somewhat okay with
that because I still don't want to waste
too much of my time
because you know you don't record it but
in the let's play I don't want to waste
time experimenting with layouts and
getting them wrong and having to redo
them so that's one of the reasons why I
keep making these videos while I am
planning on keeping to make these
time-lapse videos until I can I have a
good idea of what I didn't want to do
with the pot now at this point the
building is finished it was it really
but it was cut off because your favorite
crush and then I didn't decide to record
it anymore but yeah here's the final
result this is the the front of the
building and here's the back which is
going to be the restaurant in that
little Bay and overall I think I can say
I am pretty happy about this building
not even just necessarily like I said
because it looks ok because I'm happy
about the exteriors but also because I
think the theme the Romanian theme is
going to be awesome and this is just a
nice little Romanian Castelo I think
that's that's the way I soak up
pronouncing things I'm sorry I'm not
going to do that and if anymore the only
thing I remember from my Romanian
exchange program is that to form an a
Romanian word you take the English word
and you add looool at the end but yeah
thanks for watching and I'm sorry to all
your Romanians out there I didn't have
any too bad intentions with that I'm
going to see you all next time in which
I'm going to do I don't know yes might
be some custom scenery issues might be
some Dutch Flemish theming or it might
be more Romanian stuff maybe even some
Baltic stuff whatever I need to do
before I feel confident enough to start
a pike so I'll see you all then